radio scoop la merde et il pas tout de
suite m pokora m pokora m pokora jeudi
22 décembre 2016
aujourd'hui on a pas mal de choses à
faire une grande tournée qui commence on
a fait une belle marche avec moi moitié
qui ne veut pas encore apparaître sur la
vidéo mais j'ai travaillé au corps
croyez moi
[Musique]
à
et
135 euros il y avait une demande de mise
en fourrière
mais moi y en a un je pense que si je le
croise sa tête en mémoire ces bons
freins sur radio scoop ça non ça c'est
la maxe radio avec le staff qui
emmerdent ouais on peut dire que nous
sommes exactement on fait une pause
sur un desk jusqu'au 24 décembre
il ya le grand jeu de noël avec à gagner
notamment le nouvel iphone 7 via des
téléviseurs fait bien l'idée télé
forcément tu pourras gagner du temps
mais quand tu perds sur une structure
permettant pas qu elle s la classe côté
gourmand plus sûr est né il ya aussi ça
pour les enfants bayal et non pas mal de
cadeaux non bon compte mais derrière un
micro ou pas hahaha
radio scoop le meilleur des tubes est
tout de suite m pokora nous avons
critiqué derrière vient là bas parce
qu'on fait croire qu'on fait de la radio
mais t'en fais pas du tout de la radio
alors que nous ne voyons pas cathy ça
c'est ça c'est 4,6 à pois la stagiaire
bien voilà l'essentiel
bonjour et une bombe fiscale
[Musique]
à
merci salle et ça c'est cool là c'est la
media luz bagnols en rade qu'une
batterie chant obligés d'attendre le
dépanneur et ça c'est cool
voilà galère la guerrière la galère
merci merci merci du dépannage
[Musique]
ma copine catherine qu'on a vu ce matin
radio scoop et d'envoyer un message à
son mari vient de s'inscrire se regarde
la pêche
comme quoi ça sert tout regarder les
flops des monsieur drevet faire une
petite bouffe rapide et puis on repart
[Musique]
et toi il faut évidemment éviter les
soirées avec ça avec 7 en deux heures de
temps j'ai pris une patate dans la
gueule il a failli avaler l'alliance de
maaf à rennes et par la suite a voulu
but était l'essence c'est soit tu es
dans un pays qui est pourri - c'est loin
c'est très très loin de celui enfin loin
et franchement c'est pourquoi c'est pas
mon jardin mais c'est un peu comme ce à
quoi ça sert à la petite-pierre du
dimanche
oh ça c'est la petite balade du samedi
peut-être petite balade du vendredi et
alors le groupe nombre de mac à tahiti
cartonne boyer cartonne merci beaucoup
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si vous avez
aimé vous mettez des petits pouces vers
le haut si vous aimez pas vous mettez
des pouces vers le bas vous allez voir
la page de radio scoop parce que
franchement c'est une équipe qui est
super sympa et on s'amuse beaucoup je
vous embrasse vous donne rendez vous
demain
[Musique]